bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour
une nouvelle de nouvelle série de débats
politiques après les municipales l'an
dernier nous allons retourner aux urnes
pour les départementales dans les
yvelines comme dans le reste de la
france
nous allons désigner les 22 et 29 mars
nos représentants locaux un scrutin à
particulier cette fois ci la plupart des
cantons ont été redécoupée et ce sont
des binômes qui se présentent un homme
une femme afin de respecter les
nouvelles règles de la parité d'ici au
scrutin cinq débats à suivre sur notre
antenne chaque mardi et chaque jeudi à
19h premiers débats ont ce 3 mars il va
opposer les candidats sur le canton de
trappes qui couvre également les
communes des longs cours et de la
verrière un représentant de chacun des
binômes est présent en plateau bonsoir à
tous les quatre tout d'abord jeanine
marie candidate soutenue par le ps le
prg génération écologie vous êtes
associé au maire de la verrière alain
ajaj élus communistes mais qui n'a pas
le soutien de son parti vous êtes la
conseillère départementale sortante est
sûre trappe
enfin jean michel fourgous maire ump
d'elancourt premier vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines soutenu par
luthi également candidat avec anne capio
votre adjointe à l'éducation sur la
ville d'elancourt nicolas barrère
conseiller municipal d'opposition elle
encourt fonctionner à leurs responsables
pour cette formation de la 11e
circonscription est candidate avec vos
maris beau et puis luc miserait du front
de gauche candidat avec esther lafitte
d'europe écologie
les verts vos deux parties ont donc
décidé de faire alliance et vous êtes
élue d'opposition sur la commune de
trappes 1/5 binôme se présente également
il est composé de slimane ben oussama
directeur de l'école musulmane de saint
quentin en yvelines et 2 et karima la
suède mais aucun des deux représentants
ne pouvait être en plateau ce soir voilà
pour les présentations à la règle à
présent elle est simple le temps de
parole est chronométré chronomètre qui
s'afficheront régulièrement et on voudra
bien évidemment les temps afin de
respecter l'équilibré préconisée par le
sps a le premier tour de table
en quelques mots et pour les électeurs
les raisons de votre candidature à cette
élection on va commencer avec vous
jeanine mari pourquoi vous présenter
pour un nouveau mandat
représenter pour un nouveau mandat pour
poursuivre ce qui a été entamé sur la
ville et sur le canton puisque le canton
n'était quand on vit là on sait que
trappe et maintenant voilà l'argent
s'élèverait à 2 de communes donc encore
plus passionnant poursuivre ce qui a été
commencé peaufiner certaines choses
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que lorsqu'on a
des contrastes sur une ville avec des
objectifs à trois ans la société
évoluant rapidement il est il faut être
réactif et quelquefois intervenir en
disant non là on peut plus continuer ça
et c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
sur la prévention spécialisée
et puis ensuite il y a aussi un autre
dossier qui est important qui va changer
la ville de trappes c'est l'enterrement
de l'art de la nationale 10 ou le
conseil général intervient de façon
importante en entrée et en sortie de de
cet enterrement
et puis tout l'aménagement du plateau où
ma urba ou également le conseil général
est concerné par le pont cachin qui est
une route départementale et auquel
trappe vous voulez à surveiller le bon
déroulement de ces différentes grappes
jean michel fourgous les raisons de
votre candidature
écoutez d'abord un effondrement
macif bien sûr dans les communes de nos
moyens donc les 36000 maires de france
bien sûr on d'autant plus envie d'aller
chercher d'autres moyens notamment
conseiller général devant la situation
deuxièmement bon les grands projets nous
ces emplois parce que c'est la première
attente donc il s'agit de mieux
coordonner peut-être les moyens de la
casse qui du conseil général aurait pour
vers le développement économique bon et
puis de simplifier d'état de procédures
bon pour pour créer de l'emploi mais se
dit je suis prudent sur les promesses on
a vu nos collègues socialistes avaient
promis un million d'emplois ils ont
détruit un million d'emplois toutes
catégories donc prudents la censure mais
mobilisation sur l'emploi deuxièmement
l'éducation et l'encours est plutôt
considéré comme le modèle en france même
à l'étranger donc de de l'innovation
pédagogique pour les enfants
donc bien sûr on aimerait en faire
profiter trappe pour les moins faire
profiter également de la verrière avec
bien sûr le soutien du conseil général
notamment au niveau des collèges 1 pour
qu'il y ait une continuité et puis
dernier point la famille bien sûr avec
tout l'aspect social autour de la
famille qu'il faut renforcer ce une
valeur qui est très importante en france
qu'il faut particules en ce moment de
crise bien sûr de protéger les axes de
votre programme que vous avez développé
nous allons bien évidemment revenir sur
ses différentes compétences du conseil
général en tout cas à l'heure actuelle
puisque ces compétences sont encore en
réflexion auprès des parlementaires
c'est un petit peu particulier pour ce
scrutin les gens vont devoir se déplacer
pour aller voter mais ne sont pas sûr
encore des compétences des conseillers
départementaux puisque maintenant ce
sont des conseillers départementaux et
non plus des conseillers généraux voilà
nicolas pouhair à vous à présent les
raisons de votre candidature
cl c'est la suite logique de mon
engagement politique est la suite
logique du désir de la volonté de marine
le pen deux de nos implantés localement
ça a été fait à l'occasion des élections
municipales
maintenant ici s'est il s'agit de
s'ancrer localement et d'être présent
évidemment
en masse pour les élections
départementales je souligne d'ailleurs
que le front national présente près de
8000 candidats sur l'ensemble du pays
donc bien devant toutes les forces
politiques et dans les yvelines
on a réussi à présenter donc les 20 ans
des candidats débit nombre de candidats
sur les 21 cantons
ces 17 pour le parti socialiste et 8
pour l'ump
nous on se vide amants se présente sous
les et sous l'étiquette du front
national et pour conclure le minerai les
raisons de votre candidature ou qui est
présent sur nombreux scrutins d'ailleurs
depuis plusieurs années vous étiez
candidat aussi aux municipales sur la
ville d'autres seulement et donc nous la
problématique était celle d'un constat
le conseil général des yvelines et le
département des yvelines est un des
départements les plus riches de france
le deuxième le plus riche en
ile-de-france et en termes d'action
sociale qui est une de ces compétences
majeures
il pratique la régression sociale et
alors que les demandes et les besoins
augmentent donc ça a c'est une raison
importante
on constate qu'il y a un très grand défi
des gens par rapport à la politique et
donc nous on pense qu'il ya une
ouverture possible sur une autre
politique réellement de gauche et c'est
pour ça qu'on a participé à ce
rassemblement avec europe ecologie les
verts notamment
et enfin il ya un grand danger de cette
misère qui quitte ea ceux qui se
développent un ça a toujours été le
terreau de l'extrême droite et pour nous
c'est un très grand danger et donc on
veut lutter contre cela on va regarder
une première fois les chronomètres juste
le temps de vous préciser nous aurons
donc plusieurs thématiques abordées
elles se passent elles se basent sur les
compétences jusqu'à présent des conseils
départementaux éducation que tu as
encore développement local on va
commencer avec nicolas beau père puisque
vous êtes que le plus de retard sur le
temps de parole les chronomètres voilà
qui s'affiche aux voix 45 secondes
57 secondes pour luc miserait vous aurez
donc la parole juste après ce premier
thème c'est l'aide sociale solidarité
d'une manière générale c'est une
compétence importante pour le conseil
général les personnes en difficultés
pour se loger ou encore en situation de
handicap et puis cette question
importante occupante la question du
vieillissement de la population pour le
front national il ya des propositions
qu'on était alité par marine le pen ya
un tracteur et ça manquait encore était
le publier revalorisation de l'apa ou
encore domotique pour les personnes
âgées à domicile
et puis il ya aussi une autre idée c'est
lutter contre la fraude au rsa par
exemple ça c'est dans le domaine du
social
ben vous ferez en séance et bien que les
fraudes sociales c'est plusieurs
milliards d'euros par an il n'y a aucune
volonté politique de l'ump ou du ps de
lutter contre les fraudes sociales moi
je rappelle que le front national avait
proposé un secrétariat à secrétaire
d'état à la fraude sociale voilà et
notamment pour l'attribution du rsa il
ya énormément de fraude et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment lutter
là dessus voilà il n'ya pas que le rsa
en montant les compétences du conseil du
futur conseil départemental
aujourd'hui bien franchement je ne sais
pas qui est autour de cette table peut
savoir quelles seront les compétences du
département demain à l'issue de ces
élections parce que certes le
gouvernement qui avait annoncé la
suppression enfin je parle de manuel
valls premier ministre qui avait annoncé
la suppression du département à
l'horizon 2020 est revenu en arrière
parce qu'il s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient des élections sans risque pour
les cantons non plus plus roelens mais
enfin tout ça est encore en discussion
on voyait venir va tout à l'heure au
cours de cette émission corps de sept
heures de débat mais il faut bien partir
sur des compétences qui jusqu'à
maintenant a été en tout cas mais
justement si tu est basé tout de même
sur un programme et avancé des propos
moi je craque on arrive qu'on arrive
dans une coquille vide parce que tout a
été fait pour détricoter le département
pour transférer les compétences du
département à la région comme on a fait
comme on est en train de faire en ce
moment les transferts de compétences des
communes et aux intercommunalités et
comme on a fait les trans les transferts
de compétences et là pour le coup ça à
transfert de souveraineté entre l'état
et l'union européenne
voilà ça c'est le gros projet c'est le
grand projet de l'ump est sa part
évidemment celui de lutter contre front
national parce que c'est ça c'est la
priorité des priorités est le deuxième
grand projet du mps c'est de détricoter
la nation de détruire sur la question du
sénateur ne sont pas justes revient sur
la thématique solidarité c'est un ponton
même avant récolte quand tu auras plus
d'argent dans les caisses
il y aura plus d'être social faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont misant
sur la question du social peut-être une
réponse aussi apporter en échange qui
peut ce bien évidemment se crée autour
de cette table
enfin c'est à dire que nous déjà on
on part pas du même postulat que la
droite l'extrême droite ou ou parti
socialiste nous on part du postulat qu
on n'arrête pas de nous dire qu'il faut
se serrer la ceinture que la réalité
c'est que les richesses elle existe et
donc pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
plus de justice sociale
c'est tout à fait possible 30%
d'augmentation des dividendes versés aux
actionnaires en 2014 qui a vu son
salaire sa pension pour les retraités
augmenté de 30%
donc l'argent et existe des problèmes
dans la répartition plus équitable des
richesses alors le front national bien
sûr dénonce la fraude sociale la fraude
sociale bien sûr il faut la combattre
mais les problèmes majeurs sont voilà
les problèmes sont dans utiliser
l'argent qui existe de manière
intelligente pour faire en sorte qu'on
travaille le mieux vivre ensemble
pendant que le front national rejette
les gens et opposent les uns aux autres
nous on souhaite qu'ils aient plus de
solidarité
je voudrais pas qu'on perde soyez corps
exigences sur la question du social vous
êtes la conseillère départementale
sortante alors je vais vous faire réagir
mais pour l'instant l'assemblée
départementale est à droite
quel bilan vous faites vous du conseil
général jusqu'à présent sur le domaine
du social
l'action a été bonne jusqu'à présent de
ce qui l'émeut j'ai loupé à ce que la
ville d'elancourt avait déclassé ville
la mieux gérée des yvelines avec une de
19 sur 20 j'étais très fière et en fait
le compte général a été notée 20 sur 20
alors vous c'est quand même a priori le
département le mieux gérées de france
inde après cet indicateur bon bon voilà
maintenant
a priori les yvelines ont une très bonne
image
en france globalement sur le social et
si longtemps c'était redit stressé ses
compétences alors est-ce que les
compétences sociales vont être renforcés
du routier gnr et c'est l'économie du
conseil régional mais c'est quand même
préoccupant que en année électorale
je tiens à montrer certaines amateurisme
comme des gens qui nous gouvernent qui
sont incapables de définir
on va discuter là aujourd'hui on sait
même pas de quelles compétences
exactement va voir faire c'est quand
même pas très sérieuses et
contradictoires électeurs donc si vous
me demandez quel sort lui on est des
tendances vous les connaissez vous les
citer tous à l'heure mais on n'a pas la
précision on a quand même quelques idées
on sait que l'éducation est lé collège
reste quand même au conseil général et
les collèges il était prévu de les
transférer à la région mais pour
l'instant ce don volontaire contraire
transférer la gestion des lycées au
département oui mais ça on peut en
discuter mais pour l'instant je crois
quand même que le collège voit
maintenant le développement économique
on est quand même quelques initiatives
le social mondial le rsa il ya là pas
pour les seniors soyez il ya encore
plein de choses mais attendons
un peu la position définitive du
gouvernement et à quelques mois s'est
prononcé sur les différentes thématiques
malgré tout parce que si à chacun des
sujets sur l'existence du département
déjà en 1982 lorsqu'il ya eu le premier
volet de la décentralisation
il était aussi question de supprimer le
département et on s'est aperçu que
c'était un échelon de proximité qui
était absolument indispensable notamment
pour le social de façon à ce que les
problèmes sociaux soient traités de
manière égalitaire et équitable entre
tous les citoyens de façon à ce que
chacun les parts sont sa petite
clientèle locale
moi je souhaiterais que cela reste comme
ça je pense que cela le restera dans le
temps à venir
le département ne sera pas supprimée
c'est une annonce qui a été un petit peu
rapide avoir réflexion c'est un petit
peu dommage on peut le regretter mais
c'est comme ça sur sur le social on peut
toujours regretter que on en fasse
jamais assez le problème de ce pays
d'une façon générale et est depuis 50
ans c'est le manque d'anticipation des
problèmes à venir
on commence à s'intéresser à un problème
lorsque il explose
si on anticiper les besoins des gens je
pense que on n'arriverait pas à la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui était assez préoccupante
pour les gens on peut toujours
redistribuer l'argent à mai
c'est vrai que en même temps moi je
regarde les comptes administratifs quand
on dit ça diminue mallon quand je
regarde les lignes les lignes
budgétaires elles ne diminuent pas elles
augmentent elles augmenter pour autant
on n'a pas l'impression que cela suffise
cela veut bien dire qu'il ya des
ajustements qui ne sont pas faits en
temps et en heure et c'est peut-être là
dessus qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
vigilant à l'avenir mais je pense que le
fonctionnement même du conseil
départemental va aussi évoluer avec
cette nouvelle loi est peut-être
faudra-t-il envisager davantage de
groupes de travail de réflexion entre
élus que ce qui existe au jour
d'aujourd'hui parce que ça arrive comme
ça en délibération que ce soit en
commission on a semblé ou en commission
permanente il n'y a pas de débat avant
et l'opinion des gens n'est pas entendue
et je pense que le rôle d'un élu c'est
de faire remonter les préoccupations du
terrain voilà je vous interromps pour
que vous gardiez du temps de parole pour
la suite et que tu sais tout de vous
exprimer sur les différends que j'ai
donc on va juste qu'il sait sur la
question de l'éducation et luc miserait
vous avaient le plus de retard parlé
tout à l'heure de cette compétence
qu'aurait pu être transférées aux
régions où le département qui aurait
récupéré la compétence des délices et
sur la question de l'éducation sur la
question de la gestion des collèges quel
regard vous portez déjà mais je voudrais
attirer l'attention aussi sur quelque
chose dont le conseil général des
yvelines se désintéressent totalement
qui est qui préoccupe beaucoup les
parents c'est les entrées et les sorties
des collèges c'est à dire ce qui se
passe dehors qu'est ce qui est fait au
niveau des éducateurs de rue au niveau
de l'éducation spécialisée pareil ça
c'est quelque chose qui préoccupe
beaucoup les parents on parle beaucoup
du racket on parle de tas de choses
maintenant comment on accompagne tout
cela à l'intérieur nous on nous classe y
fit souvent comme toujours plus dense et
pas toujours plus et toujours plus de
justice sociale et les moyens existent
simplement il faut les consacrer aux
bons endroits
donc on pense que dans l'accompagnement
de nos collégiens qui est une étape de
la vie difficile l'adolescence on sait
bien il ya nécessairement une importance
particulière à attacher à cet âge là si
je parle de 2,2 ce qui se passe autour
du collège c'est que on a eu 1
par exemple la trappe un événement
dramatique il ya quelques années où un
jeune s'est fait poignarder et donc il
faut que les générations qui arrivent se
rappelle de sa pour prévenir ça et que
cette violence là ne s'installe pas et
ne perdure pas autour de nos collèges
vous n'avez pas la même approche et ça
ne surprendra personne parce qu'un front
national sur cette question de la
sécurité même aux abords des collèges
c'est la question de la
vidéosurveillance mettre fin au trafic
en plus d'interventions des forces de
l'ordre c'est ça oui je veux juste
rebondir un truc sur ce que disait
monsieur miserait les faits divers à
trappes c'était plus un non pas quatre
ans les faits divers à trappes
dramatique il y en a tous les jours il y
en a eu encore un ce matin où un jeune a
été séquestrée et battue pendant quatre
jours dans une cave à trappes donc les
problèmes d'insécurité existent sur le
canton je moi j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'ya rien qui est fait certes monsieur
fourgous sur la commune d'hallencourt à
développer la vidéoprotection donc je
pense parce que effectivement il y avait
des candidatures du front national qui
arrivait sur sa vie donc il s'est dit on
va peut-être un petit peu faire la haie
mais effectivement ce qui concerne les
collèges
il faut sécuriser parce que le conseil
général a pas vocation à intervenir dans
les programmes de l'éducation mais il
peut agir effectivement sur la
sécurisation des collèges la
vidéoprotection la lutte contre le
racket contre le trafic de drogue à la
sortie des collèges et même pour les
cons pour les quartiers dits sensibles
pourquoi pas l'installation de portiques
à l'entrée on sait très bien qu'il ya
des armes qui circulent et quand des
armes entrent dans l'enceinte du collège
c'est que vraiment il ya quelque chose
qui va pas dans ce pays on m'a dit tu as
des âmes qui circulent vous avez les
faits rapportés parce que c'est une
génération et je rêve là bien présent à
lille et brest sur la généralité
d'accord elle va juste pour préciser les
choses pour les informa noël ils sont
donnés aux gens qui nous regardent de
psychose non plus oui vraiment il y
avait des policiers qui se sont fait
tirer dessus à trappes donc bon surnom
des armes dans le canton ont été
sûrement des arts jean michel fourgous
sur la question de l'éducation ont
peut-être mettre de côté la question de
la sécurité sauf si vous souhaitez
répondre aux débatteurs qui sont
présents mais sur la question de
l'éducation c'est toute la question du
numérique que vous voulez entendre vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure en
introduction et ce serait intéressant de
faire réagir parce que vous êtes aussi
en charge de l'éducation sur la ville de
trappes donc ce sont 2 2 1 devant elle
un petit peu entre les deux méthodes
sûres c'est sur ces communes non mais ce
dilemne à risque on peut regretter c'est
que il ait pas eu plus de collaboration
ou l'a proposé vous fassiez pas vous
c'est votre chef qui refusaient bien
entendre les paroles d'un garde raoui
particulier en m'attrape bien sûr les
les méthodes que nous mettons en place
qui sont un modèle national considérés
comme tels ont beaucoup de succès
notamment sur toutes les populations de
la diversité donc c'est dommage
bien sûr alors je pense que là ce serait
l'occasion bien que vraiment vous soyez
au même niveau qu elle en cours je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup il ya peu plus d'une
centaine de trappistes qui qui
inscrivent leurs enfants dans les villes
dans la vie des longs cours justement
pour bénéficier de deux de la qualité de
ces systèmes est sûre ça améliore
l envie d'apprendre des enfants ça
améliore le plaisir d'enseigner d'un
prof c'est une réussite donc on souhaite
aller beaucoup plus loin plus vite et
bien sûr le collège le collège qu'il y
bien sûr pour l'instant conseil général
il s'agit bien sûr qu'il ait une
continuité entre l'école et le collège
et que ce soit pour l ol en cours pour
trappe pour la verrière qu'on est le
meilleur système mettant du volume de
projets vont au dernier point sur la
sécurité
je vous rappelle que l'encours porte
depuis 1 semaine le projet de
commissariats d'agglomération qu'essayer
qui a acté par le préfet et donc qui
devrait bénéficier bien sûr des méthodes
les plus pointues en matière de sécurité
donc c'est l'intérêt des trois communes
et sur deux de portée éduquons cg1 et de
la région bien sûr parce que l'agent
cofinance aussi nombre très important
d'avoir de savoir c'est un beau projet
vous avez nous avons la huitième zone
d'innovation la plus forte du monde
d'après le m haïti n'est plus belles
universités au monde qui dit qu'on est
dans la 8ème zone il rêvait profitons-en
et soyons innovantes dans l'éducation
soit innovantes dans la sécurité et je
peux dire qu'on est il ya mobilisation
générale kaski conseil général
conseiller régional notamment en plus
dans quelques mois cela ce que je veux
dire
plus celles en cours qui est comme très
porteur d'innovation voila voila ca sur
les départementales et régionales on
aura le temps d'y revenir sur la
question de l'éducation la réponse
peut-être à apporter sur la question des
tablettes par exemple tout ça le
numérique se veut bien le dire le la
problématique que des élèves de 30 n'est
pas tout à fait la même que celle
d'elancourt non quand même pas non même
pas quand même pas je peux vous le dire
oui mais justement bien donc nos
méthodes sont alors qu'en plus adapté à
vous attendez la suite le conseil
général a fait ce qu'il fallait
vis-à-vis des collèges puisque
le haut débit arrive aux portes de
chaque collège les tn y sont installés
déjà depuis un certain temps je crois
que ça date de 2005 ou 2006 avant tout
les classes pas dans toutes les classes
parce que il ya aussi un problème de
court a pas on passe de lorraine ont
économisé sur certaines choses et tous
mettez le paquet sur l'agression collège
dans le département ça ne se fait pas
comme ça avec une baguette magique sur
la ville tous les cm2 et les doubles
niveaux cm1 cm2 seront équipées de façon
à ce que lorsqu'ils vont arriver en
sixième il faisait le même niveau que
les autres collégiens et petit à petit
nous allons gagner de façon à ce que
chaque année l'ensemble des des classes
soient équipés sur le numérique moi
c'est d'une façon beaucoup plus général
que je regrette que l'état se désengage
de 7,2 cette modernité parce que quand
je regarde en europe c'est la lettonie
je crois ou à 10 ans ils sont là en
train d'inventer des robots et de les
réaliser
eh bien nous lançons pas là encore dans
notre pays sur le suivi informatique par
informatique de ce qui est de voir c'est
vrai que avec cet outil se développe une
nouvelle forme d'intelligence ce sont
les enfants que des adultes n'ont pas
forcément moi j'ai regardé des émissions
justement je crois que c'était chez vous
que ça avait été filmé un petit peu
s'ouvrir si vous voulez faire conclure
finalement l'ordinateur ni la même chose
que moi ce que j'entendais à l'école or
l'enfant entend la même chose à l'école
et pourtant quand ça passe par la voie
d'un écran ils l'assimilent à et quand
ça passe par la voix de son enseignant
il ne la signe pas et je crois que c'est
là dessus que l'éducation nationale
travaille aussi donc je pense que tout
ça est amenée à évoluer très rapidement
mais je ne suis pas opposé à ce qu'on
appelle la pédagogie mix ce que vous
vénérez line corp et ça c'est l'avenir
sur la question de développement du
développement local je vous fais
intervenir luc miserait pas ce que vous
portez à la voix du front de gauche dans
ce scrutin mais vous êtes avec un binôme
d'europe écologie les verts ee dans ce
programme commun il ya aussi à
l'importance de l'écologie politique
pour répondre aux besoins du plus grand
nombre d emplois locaux non
délocalisables à des logements à rénover
une économie réelle basée sur la
proximité aménagement du territoire et
qui n'oublie personne qui rapproche
emploi logement ça fait partie des
points de programme que vous portez
également avec avec votre votre binôme
c'est donc sur ce développement local
aujourd'hui il faut faire entrer en
ligne de compte le l'écologie
l'environnement
bien évidemment juste un petit mot sur
l'éducation quand même parce que
monsieur fourgous a une tendance
naturelle à présenter le numérique comme
la solution à tout madame marie vient de
dire que
c'était vrai que ce 7 août il a était
plus efficace que les professeurs je ne
peux pas laisser passer ça je suis moi
même un ancien enseignant la pédagogie
la pédagogie bien sûr qu'il faut
utiliser les outils les plus modernes
mais la pédagogie des enseignants
c'est ça qu'il faut renforcer monsieur
sarkozy avait supprimé la formation des
professeurs des écoles
c'était une catastrophe fort
heureusement on revient un petit peu là
dessus donc la pédagogie des enseignants
il n'y a rien de tel pour transmettre
les messages ya rien de tel maintenant
moi je répète ce que vous venez de tenir
mais les spectateurs jugeront alors sur
votre sujet et sur les questions de
données développement local et la
question de l'environnement car locales
et bien on a eu l'occasion d'échanger
lors du compte du dernier conseil
syndical avec monsieur fort où ça dessus
on pense effectivement que plutôt que
d'aider des entreprises qui nourrissent
leurs actionnaires
on ferait mieux de développer de
l'économie sociale coopératives et
solidaire qui va constituer des emplois
qui vont rester de manière locale et qui
sont utiles qu'il faille accompagner les
entreprises pour qu'effectivement ce
rapprochement entre le logement le lieu
de travail on sait que l'essentiel des
emplois sur la ville nouvelle de saint
quentin en yvelines sont des emplois qui
ont été délocalisés d'autres points de
la région ile de france
donc automatiquement il ya des gens les
couples se retrouvent avec un qui
travaillent ici l'autre qui travaille
toujours là où ils habitaient avant donc
il ya des choix qu'est qui s'opère donc
il ya au niveau des transports au niveau
du logement un effort particulier à
mettre en place par ce conseil général
je veux encore dire qu'il ne fait pas
suffisamment mais au niveau des choix
qui sont les siens il ya effectivement
vraisemblablement là un axe prioritaire
à envisager mais pas forcément de
développer les grands groupes d'aidé les
grands groupes à s'implanter plutôt
favorisé les petites entreprises locales
non mais les grands groupes i
c'est un plan qui n'ont pas besoin de me
remettre et cela il ya la banque
centrale européenne qui vient de
développer de débloquer plus de 1000
milliards d'euros on ose espérer que ce
soit pour aider le développement des
grandes entreprises européennes
je vous fait réagir jean michel fourgous
dans un instant mais nicolas beau et ça
par rapport au temps de parole je vous
donne donc la possibilité de vous
exprimer sur quatre cette question du
développement local d'aidé des grands
groupes par exemple des petites pme fait
général douane est évidemment veut
soutenir les pme et lutter contre les
délocalisations c'est pas c'est pas une
nouveauté maintenant il ya d'autres
choses évidemment on souhaite améliorer
les infrastructures des réseaux routiers
c'est encore c'est encore jusqu'à quand
je sais pas mais une compétence du
conseil départemental
on veut soutenir évidemment les services
publics de proximité
je pense notamment au service
départemental incendie secours
enfin voilà enfin encore une fois
évidemment ça coûte cher donc étant élus
dans les assemblées délibérantes des
conseils départementaux
on aurait évidemment accès aux finances
et on pourra éventuellement avoir
d'autre mot à dire sur sur les budgets
sur sur l'argent ou le distribuer
l'économie que vous affectionnez
particulièrement à écouter une amie
d'abord il faut qu'on garde nos
entrepreneurs ici et nous on trouve ne
vous aime pas quand on leur dise que
c'est des qui gagnent trop
d'argent que ça je vous rappelle que non
mais je pense à notre animé mais je
respecte tout ce qui est dit mais c'est
dit attention hein les vilains bénéfices
dont vous parlez tous ses entreprises
ses 3 % nets d'impôts du chiffre
d'affaires généré bon si on s'intéresse
un peu aux autres 97%
ce serait peut-être pas mal notamment la
part de l'état que ce serait aussi faut
inscrire être un peu un peu rigolo
arrêtons les persécuter les riches vous
savez les uns des saisons des
investisseurs et on en a besoin
aujourd'hui nos boîtes sont deux fois
moins capitalisées que leurs concurrents
anglais allemands américains
on a intérêt à attirer les riches alors
pas pour qu'ils gardent ça sur un mac là
qu'ils investissent 1 il faut les
stimuler à investir
ça c'est comme ça qu'on va relancer la
croissance que même pour payer vos
tableaux numériques interactifs il ya
passé
vous émettez à faire marcher la
croissance sinon on est tous mauriciens
à commencer par vous aussi avec vous que
le fonctionnement de votre départ les
gens juste donc l'attention pour la
production de richesse aujourd'hui vous
avez une croissance plate on était un
set quand monsieur sarkozy ont dû donner
le pouvoir aux socialistes 1,7 après une
plaie plus graves crises 0 03 04 et on
est parti pour autour de zéro pour venir
cinq ans donnons croissance vous
imaginez dans quel état on va être au
niveau d une finances publiques chers
amis
donc vous avez intérêt aujourd'hui à
dire les entreprises on en a besoin le
sait le capital qui fait se développer
une entreprise qui fait qu'elle elle
grossit qu'elles payent des taxes qui
que nous on peut redistribuer ce que
nous ne sommes que dire aux
distributeurs de richesse à l'itie
d'accord donc soyons conscients
messieurs et mesdames que vraiment
l'urgence est de se réconcilier avec
l'entreprise avec les variables même si
les gars comme des gens qui mettent qui
prennent trop d'argent bien sûr qu'il
faut il faut mais vous savez quand on
parle de ses murs et 3 % nets d'impôts
donc vous ai pas demandé un gars de
prendre un risque et dans une boîte et
déjà il prend que 3 % venaient d'impôt
de ce qu'ils génèrent il génère combien
emplois et génère une recette car le
premier profiteurs je vois pas c'est
l'état c'est plus de 50% des jeunes
autant par l'économie au travers la
casse qui s'est bien sûr de simuler une
entreprise de lui simplifier la vie
souhaité faire du conseil général vous
souhaitez réagir
oui juste un petit mot le conseil
général des yvelines a attribué une
entre une entreprise le vendredi par son
vote une subvention
le lundi est délocalisée en tunisie donc
voilà les exemples de ce qu'il faut pas
faire moi je dis pas que je condamne par
l'entreprise bien sûr qu'on a besoin des
entreprises dans leur ensemble dans
toute leur diversité
on nage et simplement pas remonter une
intervention insisté sur un aspect à mon
sens qu'il faut développer mais bien
évidemment qu'on a besoin de développer
tous les équilibres mais c'est pas ni le
conseil général ni la casse qui qui vont
apporter une aide suffisante aux grands
groupes que vous évoquez qui ont besoin
d'être accompagnés et c'est pour ça sans
doute que la bce pour la débloquer
autant marie économique c'est vrai que
c'est une compétence qui a été donnée
aux collectivités territoriales on peut
être regretter qu'il n'y ait pas une
limite à cette aide
cette aide économique parce que au
conseil général c'est l'aide à la
recherche et l'innovation dans
s'apercevoir que les grands groupes
effectivement fond cette demande de
subvention et que les pme qui en ont
bien besoin qu'ils sont aussi
innovatrice que les grands groupes mais
qui ne sont peut-être pas organiser en
interne de façon à aller chercher toutes
les ressources auxquelles peuvent
prétendre
mais on ne les voit pas on en voit très
peu moi ce que j'en ai vu deux là il
n'ya pas très longtemps
ça c'est regrettable parce que les
grands groupes je pense on à l'intérieur
en ressources humaines et en ressources
financières la nécessité de trouver les
fonds pour pour pour investir sinon si
les grands groupes nationaux ne peuvent
pas trouver deux ou trois millions à
l'intérieur là vraiment il ya un autre
problème
moi je suis pour favoriser plutôt les
pme parce qu'elles sont des entreprises
de deux créatrices d'emplois locaux
j'achète important car si vous souhaitez
vous exprimer son développement
économique réagir à ce qui a été dit ce
avait eu une bonne minute de retard sur
le temps de parole vous pouvez en
profiter
j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire je peux
prendre une minute de pain de pas
vraiment à ce que m'a dit vous allez les
rattraper tout ça l'erreur vous
inquiétez pas voilà en tout cas pour les
quelques thématiques ne pouvait aborder
on va marquer une pause avec un micro
trottoir réalisé sur ce canton de
trappes qui couvrent je vous le rappelle
également les villes de la verrière et v
l'encours qu'attendez vous de vos
conseillers départementaux ils sont
dorénavant de assiégé voici vos réponses
nous transports en commun si c'est
parfait mais il ya encore de petits
trucs à améliorer quoi un peu moins de
pollution
les bus sans pollution refaire un petit
peu les deux trappes et à il ya quelque
chose à faire lundi ce côté là j'attends
beaucoup il au niveau bas au niveau de
la de l'école qui est qui et déjà qu'ils
aient des soutiens scolaires qui est bas
qu'ils investissent un peu plus sur
l'éducation
on définit pas réellement leurs
compétences et ça ils nous l'expliquent
jamais c'est toujours quelque chose de
vague
ils promettent des tas de choses mais
sans le définir ce qui le ce en quoi ils
sont réellement compétents du social
beaucoup puisque façon période de crise
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont en difficulté et voilà je pense que
même avec un gouvernement socialiste
je trouve que le social tu n'as pas ira
pas assez le débat consacré aux cantons
de trappes qui se poursuit sur tv fil
avec les candidats un représentant des
binômes pour qu'ils vous pourrez voter
les 22 et 29 mars on vient d'entendre
quelques attentes des citoyens envers
leurs conseillers généraux conseillers
départementaux
on peut re préciser que les compétences
sont en discussion puisque le projet de
loi portant sur une nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république qui doit répartir les
compétences entre les régions les
départements et les communes est encore
en cours d'examen à l'assemblée
nationale le vote définitif du texte ne
devrait intervenir qu'après les
élections à chacun je vais vous demander
quelles sont les compétences qui vous
semblent aujourd'hui essentielle pour le
département nicolas boël est ce que tout
ça doit être redéfinie qu'attendez vous
le département est un échelon
essentielle entre
la commune et l'état nous au front
national on défend le triptyque communes
département et à lui un ps défend le
triptyque intercommunalités communauté
d'agglomération communautés urbaines jeu
pac man l'appel région et futur hyper
région europe et les hypers région le
jour où elle chevaucheront deux nations
ça sera la fin des nations parce que
l'état ne peut pas donner des directives
à deux états ne peut pas donner de
directives à une région c'est donc que
les régions prendront les ordres
directement de bruxelles et donc l'état
sera inutile et c'est donc la mort des
nations souveraines sur les compétences
même des conseils départementaux
maintenant ils sont justement vous
souhaitons aujourd'hui d'actualité mais
qui demain le peut-être ne le seront pas
donc moi j'ai l'impression justement
quelles sont les compétences dans le
vent vous souhaitez signer notre amenés
à siéger sur quelles compétences vous
souhaitez avoir un défendra le
département et les compétences actuelles
du département donc rester sur les bases
qui sont jusqu'à présent à donner c'est
bien sûr mais il y aura des propositions
sur par exemple faire transférer les
compétences de la région certaines
compétences vers le département
voilà mes jambes et les genoux on n'est
pas bon entre départements et régions
et bien non je vous ai dit je viens de
vous expliquer ce que ce que nous on
défend la commune le département l'état
c'est aussi simple que ça mais
l'occasion de développer un deuxième set
horrible sont en paroles mais s'ils ne
souhaitaient pas développé j'ai bien
entendu on criera pas de y'a pas de
soucis au moment où les chronomètres
s'arrêteront l'utiliserai pour vous
faire réagir sur les compétences que
vous souhaitez voir venir ou en tout cas
que le département pourrait conserver
déjà on
on part d'une idée fausse qui nous est
rabâché sans arrêt c'est celle du
millefeuille
mais à chaque degré il ya des intérêts
donc il faut il ya peut-être des
réajustements à trouver mais cette
utilité de la proximité est importante
et le département
il est important pour cela à nos yeux et
donc qui est le champ de compétence et
est quand même assez large de champ
d'intervention du conseil général futur
conseil départemental le social c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
l'éducation on l'a vu au travers des
collèges mais pas uniquement la jeunesse
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important
et quoi de mieux que les réseaux de
proximité pour travailler des sujets
comme cela mais le conseil général
intervient également sur sur des notions
de santé par exemple
et quand on voit que par exemple qui
pratiquent aujourd'hui des regroupements
qui vont éloigner les lieux
d'accessibilité des gens et bien sûr
c'est toujours les plus démunis qui en
subissent les conséquences
ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
grave donc on a parlé des transports n'a
parlé du logement n'a parlé de l'emploi
sa sélection voit que les sujets qui
touchent le plus nos concitoyens à
différents échelons pour des
responsabilités
diverses et
ces différentes ces différents échelons
sont intéressés dans la mise en place
d'une politique visant à travailler au
mieux-être ensemble sur cette question
du millefeuille administratif qui a été
évoqué cette fausse idée un selon luc
miserait aujourd'hui vous êtes d'accord
il ya toutes les structures sont
nécessaires il ya les départements il ya
les régions il ya les intercommunalités
qui vont encore s'étendre à 10,6 à d'ici
à 2016 le département est nécessaire au
milieu de tout ça non mais écoutez nous
les positions et sam vous la connaissez
on avait un seul conseiller pour la
région le département
on l'a fait voter et ceux ci disent
comme des vies toutes sont arrivées on
démolit tout et on remplacer par quoi je
n'ai pas très bien compris mais bon cela
dit goûter aujourd'hui dans les danses
qui est fortement demandée nous c'est
bien entendu qu'une qu'on garde aussi
une partie conomique parce que c'est la
première attente de nos administrés et
en plus il faut une union m'écouter les
joueurs enfin la clique de ma liste
entre guillemets c'est modem du diy
l'ump écologie bleus voilà on a quand
même beaucoup de monde et on a on a déjà
la casse qui selon un le conseil général
de man âge et et moi je suis allé à
l'union européenne de ne pas des boutons
sa figure un bon j'y suis allé je suis
allé voir monsieur de nom de la masse au
jeu les voir monsieur lamassoure qui est
quand même le président de la commission
du budget de la première puissance
mondiale qui est l'union européenne et
je vais parler du projet du problème du
financement pour l'espace de
saint-quentin de comment on pouvait
trouver des moyens supplémentaires pour
créer un fonds pour 2 p no no no no
entreprises de cet espace bien sûr de
nouveaux moyens
idem idem le vous parlez de rapprocher
les gros les petits fameux dit
rapprocher d'entre eux bien sûr
bien entendu le business avec ses draps
rapprocher les grosses entreprises des
petites ça au niveau du conseil général
bien entendu qu'on est très bien placé
pour le faire
et puis également l'apprentissage on est
on est tous dépassé les élus on le voit
bien avec les contrats d'apprentissage
on trouve une place dans une entreprise
parce qu'elles sont tellement écrasés
par les charges par par les contraintes
de 35 heures par cycle du très bon et
bien le contrat l'an lors les emplois
d'avenir il faut les convertir en emploi
d'apprentissage et qu'on puisse enfin
remettre nos jeunes qui vont vers le
secteur marchand belle certes productif
de richesse dont on a sacrément besoin
il faut ça c'est une proposition celle
des prix élevés ne soutenons en tout cas
et on va chercher les moyens là vous
nous parler de développement économique
c'est très bien moi j'aimerais bien oui
je veux je vous rejoins sur une grande
partie de votre analyse sur le
développement économique
mais le développement économique c'est
une compétence de la région c'est pas du
tout de compétence du département
donc je ne comprends pas que qu'on
discute sur le développement économique
ou alors peut-être que c'est que c'est
une thématique qui a été écrite pour
vous non mais il ya des trois ans qu'il
faut qu'ils ne ba oui ou 15 qui
consisterait conseiller régional et
européen en 2004 et par est un moulin
toutefois pas de la compétence du
département le développement économique
il y connaît aujourd'hui une peut-être
qu'effectivement ça serait une bonne
chose d'énorme action devenir la
compétence du développement kfw dans le
code général des collectivités locales
voilà si les communes voulait aider au
financement du développement économique
de certaines entreprises
elle pourrait être saisie de la même
manière que le conseil régional ou que
le conseil départemental elle commune le
libre à elle de répondre ou ne pas
répondre
c'est une compétence aussi communal sur
le code général des collectivités
locales donc on ne peut pas improviser
là dessus sur le développement
sur le pêcheur éventuellement
redistribuées j'aimerais avoir si votre
regard puisqu'on vous qui siégeaient
aujourd'hui au sein de ce conseil
départemental vous êtes les lieux
sortante les compétences aujourd'hui
telle qu'elle existe suffisance brothers
à la recherche et l'innovation
voilà le conseil général est saisie de
beaucoup de grands groupes pour cette
demande de subvention pourquoi pas
puisque la loi les y autorise mais je
regrette simplement je le répète puisque
les pme n'est pas à l'intérieur de les
ressources nécessaires pour monter les
dossiers auxquels elles peuvent
prétendre comme
comme la porte à d'autres compétences à
redistribuer aussi par rapport à la
région avec actuellement la discussion
de cette nouvelle organisation
territoriale alors si le lycée des 102
au conseil général on peut espérer que
les lycées soit aussi bien entretenue
que les conseils que les collèges du
département voilà le concernant le lycée
de la plaine de l'eau clé dans un état
pas très valorisant
au regard des résultats puisque les
résultats sont bons désormais chercher
dans ce lycée je trouve que l'état du
lycée est assez déplorable et si le
département hérite de ce mauvais
héritage on peut espérer que d'autres
lycées aussi du département verront
peut-être une façade et à l'intérieur
surtout plus vivable pour relie serre
voilà on va faire la matière de sécurité
qu'on va faire un dernier tour de table
à présent pour conclure ce débat est
justement vous allez à nous exposer vos
conclusions vos attentes on peut
peut-être aussi revenir sur cette
disparition ou non des conseils
départementaux est-ce que c'est
nécessaire ou pas on vous a déjà plus ou
moins entendu sur ces questions là annie
collaborèrent on commencera avec vous
vous avez de bonnes minutes pour pour
pour conclure si vous le souhaitez pas
très bien alors je voudrais quand même
on peut pas vraiment parler du conseil
départemental notamment des yvelines
si on dit pas un mot sur le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
monsieur pierre bédier
je vais donc rappeler brièvement peu
l'historique de monsieur bédié alors je
vais juste vous interrompre avant oui
mais si vous êtes vraiment et que j'ai
que deux minutes et vous aurez vos
minutes j'ai pas dis je vous les prenez
d'abord il me semble je veux juste
préciser que faire bédié est candidat
dans un autre canton que ne couvrons pas
ici pour les téléspectateurs de
téléphone monsieur les allées lui porter
une attaque il n'aura pas là monsieur
murray dont monsieur bédié et le
président du conseil des hauts et les
nomades avec vous vous expliquiez
insolent l'ensemble des compétences a
indiqué moi j'aurais préféré vous vous
exprimiez sur la question des
compétences du département c'est bien
mais moi je fais ce que je vois je vais
m'excuser ce camp sur monsieur prix les
attaques sur pierre bédier je suis
monsieur bédié a été condamné c'est à
sète un repris de justice qui à la tête
du département collaborèrent monsieur
bédié ump monsieur le pen a aussi été
condamné dan et à mesure fois qu'un
président de nom du pire vtt condamné à
dix-huit et marrant comment vous avez
pas envie que on parle de bédié pour le
couvrir georges et collabore vous
interromps tout de suite et vous voyez
bien vous m'avez fait bondir ne sommes
pas là pour le couvrir en tout cas pas
en ce qui me concerne c'est ce qu'il me
semble que jusqu'à présent vous mets ma
carte dans aucun parti politique
je vous précise tout simplement que car
bédié est candidat sur un autre canton
il n'est pas l'armée sait que c'est
important pour les fédérales a consacré
le fonctionnement du conseil donc vous
appeler les électeurs à voter pour vous
sur béziers qu'on est super dié a été
condamné selon vous à 10 très bien ce
que je peux en mettre deux minutes de
papa sur ses seins bédié je suis désolé
il n'est pas là pour lbg souvenir des
faits c'est un pas il n'est pas la
victoire nicolas boël perdait du temps
vous perdez du temps pour le coup vous
perdez du temps
non monsieur bedie la rue quand nicolas
n'est pas vous laisser parler accueilli
cinquante mille euros d'amendé six ans
d'inéligibilité pour corruption car
bédié n'est pas là pour vous répondre
en outre sociaux vous êtes candidat sur
le canton janvier a fait appel je sais
je sais qu'ici je sais que cyril notre
surnom damnation a été confirmé en 2008
par la cour d'appel de paris en mai 2013
quatre ans plus tard c'est à dire qu'il
ya également des remises de peine pour
les élus à vous appeler condamné la
corée sociaux nicolas beau il revient
aussi sur le tabac et avoir purgé sa
peine si ça c'est important que les
français le sachent débat sans quand son
ami michel vialay ump actuellement maire
de mantes-la-jolie avait a démissionné
dans la foulée ce qui a permis est ce
qui a permis une nouvelle élection
partielle à mantes-la-jolie avec
également le remplaçant de michel vialay
qui était madame bédié comme par hasard
en juillet 2013 monsieur bédié gagne le
deuxième tour face à la candidate
socialiste avec plus de 60% des voix
atteignant parfois les 70 % ces sommes
serviront un mur sur les 10 euros
culturel du val fourré attendez c'est
pas mal je vous laisse 30 secondes mais
14 à la suite de la démission d'alain
schmitt
il est réélu à la présidence du conseil
général des yvelines avec la complicité
des conseillers généraux ump et
peut-être même ps voilà très bien merci
nicolas beau père si vous souhaitez
répondre sur cette question permet liés
je vous en prie notamment sur la
question de la complicité vous parler
sur sa réélection si vous ne vous est
pas nécessaire ce on va continuer non
non regardez les votes et vous verrez
alors la règle et regarderai ces publics
donc merci d'avoir dans votre dossier
est donc on continue ce tour de table
pour vos conclusions concernant le
canton trappe
s'il vous plaît ne miserait ben moi ce
que j'espère déjà les pierres mais sinon
non non pas du tout ce que j'espère
c'est qu'il ya énormément de
téléspectateurs de téléphiles parce
qu'ils vont constater
que le front national l'extrême droite
mais c'est son habitude au sujet qui
vous êtes l'extrême droite au sujet qui
sont posées a toujours répondu autre
chose que le sujet qui était donc ça
pourrait être instructif monsieur
fourgous nous a présenté tout à l'heure
l'ensemble des composantes qui se réunit
autour de sa liste il a dans ses
derniers tracts évoqué le fait que lui
ils étaient rassemblés on a la preuve
que l'extrême droite parra semble pas
tout tout tout roule à droite
dans le même temps
madame jeannine mari qui quelquefois à
prendre des positions avec la droite
départementale puisqu'elle était exclu
du groupe de gauche
est ce que vous créez pas monsieur
fourgous que vous soyez un petit peu
coincé et que vous ayez par rapport à
vos espoirs sur ce canton
quelques difficultés et en tout cas tout
ça tout ce jeu politicien ne répond pas
aux attentes réelles
là on a un grand danger devant nous
c'est l'abstentionnisme est donc moi je
souhaiterais attirer l'attention des
téléspectateurs là dessus il faut qu'ils
se mobilisent qu'il n'est pas la
prétention qui votent tous pour nous
mais là qui s'expriment sur ce scrutin
mais qui s'exprime
déjà parce que c'est extrêmement
important
notre démocratie est en danger et donc
les les élections ne sont pas l'unique
moyen de l'expression de cette
démocratie mais c'en est un qu'il s'en
saisissent et qui votent pour ce
rassemblement que nous représentons
europe ecologie les verts le front de
gauche parti communiste jean-michel
fourgous pour conclure peut-être sur
l'abstention aussi sur l'importance de
se mobiliser si vous le souhaitez oui
alors écoutez moi je dirais je vous
rappelle quand même nous nos objectifs
nous c'est bien sûr d'abord l'emploi un
bon il donc de simplifier la vie des
entrepreneurs faire un guichet unique
d'ailleurs pour les chômeurs et pour les
entrepreneurs simplifier les choses plus
de sécurité pour nos commerçants il ya
une très grosse attente donc
intensification mis sur la
vidéosurveillance sur sur trappe et sur
la verrière plus d'efficacité pour le
rsa parce que il faut l'oeil il faut
leur centre est où c'est bien bon un
fonds de soutien fort pour nos pme qui
vont être en danger pendant deux ans
deux ans il y aura très peu de
croissance donc ça va tomber et une
augmentation de 40 % des dépôts de bilan
mesdames messieurs sur les yvelines en
un an
donc voilà il faut s'y préparer on
savait qu'on est dur éducation on vous
l'a dit équiper nos collèges et les
écoles mais sûr de la mairie trappe pour
être dans le top pour pour les résultats
ce chrono 2
enfant intensifs il soutient ce corps
qui est déjà en place à trappes il vous
reste une trentaine de la famille à
améliorer les dispositifs de maintien à
domicile des seniors des gardes
d'enfants bien sûr sécurité on l'a dit
vidéo nouveau commissaire
d'agglomération secousses assez près
voilà et et surtout rassembler vous êtes
dans une superbe zone d'innovation
soyons d'abord une vente soyons positifs
soyons soyons bâtisseurs plutôt que bon
voilà toutes façons beaucoup de choses
sont joués on sait très bien dans quelle
direction ce qui va se payer ce passé à
peu près dans ce pays bon soyons
positifs et pensions à l'emploi
notamment à tous ceux qui l'ont perdue
et à nos entreprises sion qui attendent
des mesures rassemblées de compétences
ou la mettant la compétence au centre
dans les yvelines et dans ce nouveau
projet du conseil général merci marie
une minute trente à peu près pour
conclure je crois que la compétence au
niveau du conseil général elle existe à
je crois qu'il a fait ses preuves là
dessus sinon il reprend du vin sur vin
comme vous l'avez dit au niveau de sa
gestion ce qu'on peut en attendre c'est
peut-être un petit peu plus d' écoute
des besoins qui pourrait remonter et qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas forcément pris
en compte parce que le système même du
fonctionnement du conseil général fait
que ça ne peut pas être voilà ça c'est
un peu regrettable on arrive à avoir des
actions justement sur la prévention
spécialisée qui a qui a fusionné dans
l'état ancien vers une association
départementale qui s'est bien
prophétique et professionnels en la
matière et on s'aperçoit qu'en six mois
les résultats sont quand même très très
encourageant par rapport aux actions
qu'ils mènent donc de ce côté là quand
on voit bien que quand à sa remontée
directe de l'élu local et que l'on fait
qu'on peut agir ça se passe bien je
regrette simplement que ça ne se passe
pas sur davantage de dossiers et
davantage de dossiers qui intéressent
l'ensemble des yvelinois pas seulement
une action locale
on avait travaillé ensemble sur les
enseignants référents d'enfants
handicapés
c'est quelque chose qui s'est passé dans
mon canton parce que c'est un autre
conseiller qui a été saisi mais qui m'a
donné le dossier j'ai on a réglé le
problème au niveau du canton la règle et
aussi au niveau du département et le
regret que ce formule
le dis très très clairement c'est que
justement on n'est jamais l'occasion de
travailler au niveau 2 du département
dans son ensemble parce que si on
travaille sur son compte on s'intéresse
que son canton c'est pas intéressant si
on est si on travaille au niveau de
l'ensemble du département c'est tous les
cantons et compris le mien qui est
intéressé donc je pense qu'à une
nouvelle façon de travailler qui
pourrait se mettre en place puisque les
compétences c'est la façon de
fonctionner qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait la place militants s'il ya
compétence là il ya compétences dans les
services la compétence des compétences
et s était au delà de ça c'est sur la
façon de travailler que ce serait vous
sembler ça vous sembler important vous
êtes à peu près tout ça à 10 minutes
l'équilibré est quasiment respecté
nicolas beau arrive reste une minute si
vous le souhaitez vous exprimer je vous
passe la parole sur cette question du
canton si le tram mais ma conclusion si
vous souhaitez réagir et vrai six
minutes de temps de parole pour vous
exprimer sur le canton trappe sur les
compétences sur vos propositions et pas
sur pierre bédier s'il vous plaît très
bien je crois que les français ils ont
ils ont un peu soupé de de l'alternance
gauche droite gauche droite qui finit
par nous endormir
ça a un effet un peu hypnotique non nous
on propose une alternative et une
alternative crédible parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des élus qui sont
implantés localement dans les conseils
municipaux sans expérience dont
l'expérience on la gagne fergus mais
c'est pas une garantie
elles se gagnent dans les assemblées
elle se gagne sur le terrain
nikolas brouillard ils ont entraîné
reprenait le fil vous réalisiez
basselier j'ai très bien chanter ainsi
que monsieur fourgous pour ma conclusion
donc nous on propose une alternative aux
français
merci à vous quatre va revoir les
chronomètres une dernière fois ce débat
sera rediffusé notamment samedi 7 mars
20h dimanche également 8 mars à 10
heures il est aussi retrouver sur notre
site internet grâce au replay quant au
prochain est débat il sera consacré
jeudi 5 mars à 19h au canton de maurepas
à très bientôt sur tv fier